delia is with us in Houston Texas ideal
yeah how are you hi good afternoon thank
you for taking my call sure my question
today is do we need to sell our house my
husband and I we have about a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars in debt
all sorts
last year we cleared about 125 but also
we had a big life change that has excuse
me that happened start I guess our
annual money this year is going to be
about 40,000 in 2015 which was last year
in November my husband was diagnosed
with leukemia we're still fighting it
but thanks to you we were able to change
a lot of our insurances so we right now
currently we're having about $3,200 of
income coming into the house but our
household runs off of 5,000 so we're
still short we we did have some money
saved but we have already dwindling down
we have about maybe ten thousand dollars
left with the insurance cost it's over a
thousand dollars that we're paying right
now so I just don't know what else we
need to do we're doing fundraisers the
community has been a big support but
we're still looking about another year
he has not had he doesn't have a
treatment yet that is working
so what md anderson is doing right now
is just maintaining his illness and
keeping him alive but financially it is
it's destroying us so so I'm not quite
sure if you have any advice right now
I'm sorry you're getting hit on all
sides with this it's pretty scary
well what the hundred and twenty five
thousand in debt does that include your
mortgage that includes our mortgage how
much of that is your mortgage about
seventy five thousand and what's what's
the house worth probably about a hundred
and forty hundred and fifty so we do get
some equity in that house yeah and
what's the 50,000 in debt um it's
student loans and then we have a vehicle
okay how much is vehicle a vehicle is
about 20 put student loans on hardship
to firown' sell the car okay before I
sell the house we I thought about that
and if we're about maybe three to four
thousand dollars short
and I even debated to do that but then
that would slash that little reserve
that we have and it's a five hundred
dollar car payment yes it is you're
right and you can't afford it okay the
five hundred you know you cuz you're
upside down by your budget so we down
and that that five hundred on our car
payments a big part of it okay
so you've just got a and I know you're
traveling to MD Anderson and so forth
and you know you got some stuff like
that you're doing but I'm gonna that
cars a big thing and that you see if you
get if all you've gots this little house
payment and it is a little house payment
then it we get you but a lot closer to a
break-even mathematical survival on the
budget survival okay and keep working
that because what I really want to be
able to do is you know take a machete to
enough of these things in your life that
we can get the math balanced so that you
can concentrate only on cancer or not
cancer and money right and it says you
got a big fight on your head on your
shoulders we do you have to literally do
how old is he he's 44 good this is that
it good know that well that's a good
thing but it's where he's gone through
three three treatments that have not
worked on the fourth one and we're
thinking it's not working and still yes
so we we have a long road still but we
do thank you for everything though
because because of us learning from you
I have learned how to budget we both did
and we've also changed our insurance to
include short term disability in the
long term disability so that has helped
us tremendously
have you guys is there anything we're
going to be in Houston doing the smart
conference want you to come as our guest
I'd love to give you a day off
you take a day off from cancer and a day
off from Orion we'll just pour blessings
on you a little bit here thank you yes
thank you that would be awesome
what's his first name so we can pray for
him his name is Adam okay cool well you
hold on and Kelly will pick up and you
tell her anything else you need in any
way we can serve you guys and help you
while you're fighting this we will and
anything we can do Kelly whatever she
wants just just take care of her
certainly conference smart conference
with VIP seats for sure just in case you
thought you had a problem today goodness
it just doesn't happen on other
financial shows but it reminds us that
when we you know can get herself
straightened out financially how much
stronger a position we're in to fight
against Murphy in life when they come
knocking at our door and 500 all our car
payments student loans are just not
conducive to that it just it just it
makes everything harder and oh I can
afford this car oh all students have a
student loan not after you take calls
like that for 30 years not after you
take calls like that this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income on a $500,000 in
economy
you